olá chris anderson presidente do ted
mundial
ele diz que pesquisas revelaram por meio
de estudos e incite os arqueológico sims
a centenas de anos que as pessoas
costumavam se sentar de frente a uma
fogueira para ouvir um ancião para
trocar idéias e depois ela celebravam no
mundo atual
segundo ele a grande fogueira é o mundo
estamos todos conectados e por meio de
uma plataforma podemos apresentar nossas
ideias e de repente simultaneamente
essas idéias são ouvidas por milhares e
milhares de pessoas
foi olhando para esse cenário que o
colégio visconde de porto seguro
assim pensou e se nós participar cimo de
um evento sediasse mussum evento e
trouxéssemos a voz ea visão de uma
criança e foi isso que nós fizemos a
final será que existe algo mais inovador
do que o brotar de uma semente do que
espiar mos o futuro através de uma
janela e essa janela são sonhos
representam os sonhos e os olhares das
nossas crianças
quando perguntamos a elas porque que
vocês deveriam participar e vários
grupos foram trazendo essas respostas
mas esse grupo disse assim porque nós
falamos as coisas de um jeito mais
simples e aí pode ser que as pessoas
entendam que a situação é grave
outro grupo disse equipe e eles também
que eles serão os governantes da manhã e
por que eles podem dar as suas ideias só
quando eles forem adultos eles podem
falar agora teve um grupo que disse nós
não temos assim uma grande idéia nós
temos um começo de uma ideia e essa
ideia pode ser
ilhada pode ser melhorada e teve uma
menina que diz olha nós achamos que os
adultos estão meio confusos eles andam
muito preocupados pra lá e pra cá e pode
ser que a gente com mais tempo livre com
mais imaginação possa ter uma idéia mas
lá no fundo todos eles todos todos
disseram que eles querem muito
contribuir e acham que se nós abrimos um
pouco essa voz esse espaço para essa voz
com certeza eles adentraram junto
conosco porque eles são os mestres do
futuro e o desenvolvimento dessas
habilidades comunicativas que vão se
desdobrar em diálogos talvez seja a
maior competência necessária para o
entendimento global
hoje eles estão aqui eles não estão
todas as noites em frente à fogueira
ouvindo o ancião mas com certeza cada
face traz o conjunto de faces de todos
os seus ancestrais e se neste momento
professores do mundo todo leva um mundo
para a sala de aula
nós começamos a fazer um outro movimento
que irmos com eles pra grande sala de
aula que é um mundo muito obrigado